like talk to me about like [__] like
prostituting yourself for drugs is it
true that you did like crazy [__]
like weird gay stuff that and you're not
gay i would let men blow me i would
never blow the men okay right um there
was standards there
yeah is this in your book yeah that's
how my first book starts at the very
first chapter yeah yeah so you're okay
with just going hard in the paint on
this one right here
it's like a monday morning
yeah i felt pretty comfortable asking
that question yeah brandon's an open
book yeah yeah
totally if i'm not i'll just not answer
it right um but yeah uh
so and it got to a point where you know
you said it tonight um you know
with your
lux you're in this amazing relationship
and she says hey we're in a relationship
but you say it better than i i'll [__]
this up but
intimate you don't need to show your
body to everybody right and you're like
but everything's a million times funnier
if i'm naked right right so
so for me i had did so many things
in addiction right like the prostitution
parts to then like
you know my character on viva la van was
nudie novak so it was just naked
everywhere and then like we were doing
the [__] face unstoppable tour which was
bam's band yeah and i remember doing
this interview in australia and and the
interviewer said
we hear that there's like some
homosexual tendencies that take place on
stage
are you a homosexual and i'm like are
you calling me
gay
and i don't give a [__] and and and i'm
like you're calling me gay and i push
him down and i pull his pants down and
like bam a couple hold him down and i
pull his dick out and i do two pumps
just to prove that i wasn't gay
and i left the [__] interview you
know so i did all this weird [__] and
and this is how i realized that i wasn't
gay and i love gay people at some point
because you you did two pumps yeah i got
his dick in your mouth just to prove
that it was didn't enjoy it
right there
that was that wasn't my thing that well
here's where i realized about my thing
later on down the road i end up in this
recovery house
and i want to like jerk off one day and
dude that's a serious crime to like
physically like push someone down
over that really fast
i was like on the next hoping that what
year was that
[__] everything's kind of a blur during
those years probably
limitations
at least whatever whatever it needs to
be that's how long it was exactly right
so you let guys suck your dick but you
never sucked anyone else's dick unless
they called you gay yeah
yeah
but would you jerk guys off no it was
never like a thing
like that's not really what they were
looking for for some reason that's the
thing in that world you let guys suck
your dick but what if they wanted to eat
your ass i used to i used to live with
this guy would that be like more
i would negotiate totally but i used to
let i used to let a guy shave my [__]
he just wanted to shave it for how much
uh like 20 40 i lived with him 20 40
bucks whatever he had yeah [__] man
shave it
interesting
you have to grow it out for him to pay
you again
i wasn't really a health and wellness
kind of guy at that point so when he was
ready i dropped trout like
it wasn't anything great going on but so
i ended up in this recovery house
and this is back when vcrs are in play
and right and i want to jerk off and
there's these two guys
brian and donovan who are like
openly flamboyantly gay guys and they're
amazing guys
but i'm looking all through the house
for a porn can't find one and in brian's
room he's not there
there's a porn in the vcr and i press
play and it's a gay porn and i'm like
you know what this is a perfect time for
me to answer the [__] inevitable
question am i gay and i watched the porn
with a complete open mind to see if i
got a hard [__] and i didn't
so i i think that kind of answered the
question but did you try i i wasn't
opposed to it you know like i wasn't she
did try yeah totally i mean
i like held my dick kind of like plate
caressed it you know danced with it a
little bit all right it's put on a date
it's it's just after gay porn
technically
i i i
uh
i have a guy's come in me
but it's i've never been [__]
it's like kind of like that magic trick
where you do where you get on your back
and you drink the thing with your feet
right right so me and ben were like up
doing blow for like five days straight
and after like day three delusional
paranoid [__] gets weird so
5am probably fourth or fifth day in
out of our minds hadn't slept a minute
we're shooting a game of pool
and we have one of our tattoo artists
there with us
i win the game of pool
we then go into the bedroom i lay on the
bed
ben puts a pillow over my head he pulls
a laptop out and puts porn on
and jerks off and comes onto my arm
and then we bring the tattoo artist in
and he traces around it and then without
no ink on it he then puts the [__] into
my arm
see that right there
in me that's never [__] in me you know
what i mean
wow
i've never heard of that before yeah
that's that that's the nbd right there
they got blood brothers and then they
got my brother
yeah and but the whole thing is just so
wrong that it's kind of right
yeah i i wanted to give you guys it's
not even that wrong yeah you know you
won smoking
trying to like bet people 100 bucks they
could guess what it was and then one
time i was in the airport and the
the bartender
who was a a pretty openly gay guy i'm
like yo if you can guess this i'll give
you a hundred bucks he goes oh honey
that's [__]
[Laughter]
buy one glass of wine i had to tip 100
bucks on cause i only had a card i'm
like dude that's it
yeah dude that's epic man yeah i i love
that you're uh
that you're so candid and transparent
dude
it's
why not man right dude i [__] dig
that and and um to be clear i really
hope that uh that i wasn't disrespectful
in any other it wasn't my intention to
be dude
i know that it would never be right like
i know you and i know kind of i know
what your sobriety is like and i know
that you're way past that point of like
trying to pull like out of left field
thing sure and i'm not out to make
anybody feel bad i'm not out to like you
know i know that to to harm anybody but
at the same time i also like just
don't know how to have a filter and so
if i'm curious about something i'm just
gonna
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never been allowed to do for jackass and
a lot of it is flagrantly illegal so
it's adults only and if you live in any
of these states then you better go to
stevo.com and check out my tour schedule
hurry up and get your tickets too
because it's selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]